sometimes the basics are fun to
explore because they're not so basic
what do you what is interpretability
what do you what does it look like what
are we talking about it looks like
we took a much smaller
set of Transformer layers than the ones
in the modern bleeding edge
state-of-the-art systems
and after applying nefarious
tools and mathematical ideas and trying
20 different things we found we have
shown it that this piece of the system
is doing this kind of useful work
and then somehow also hopefully
generalizes some fundamental
understanding of what's going on that
generalizes to the bigger system
you can hope and it's probably true like
you would not expect the smaller tricks
to go away when you have a system that's
like doing larger kinds of work you
would expect the larger work kinds of
work to be building on top of the
smaller kinds of work and gradient
descent runs across the smaller kinds of
work before it runs across the larger
kinds of work and well that's kind of
what is happening in Neuroscience right
it's trying to understand the human
brain by prodding and it's such a giant
mystery and people have made progress
even though it's extremely difficult to
make sense of what's going on in the
brain they have different parts of the
brain they're responsible for hearing
for Sight division science Community
that's understanding visual cortex I
mean they've made a lot of progress in
understanding how that stuff works like
and that's I guess but you're saying it
takes a long time to do that work well
also it's not enough so in particular
um
let's say you have got your
interpretability
tools and they say that your
your current AI system is plotting to
kill you
now what
it is definitely a good step one right
yeah what's step two
if you cut out that layer is it going to
stop
waiting to kill you when you optimize
against visible
misalignment you are optimizing against
misalignment and you are also optimizing
against visibility
so sure you can yeah it's true all
you're doing is removing the obvious
intentions to kill you you've got your
detector it's showing something inside
the system that you don't like okay say
the disaster monkey is running this
thing
will optimize the system until the
visible bad behavior goes away
but it's arising for fundamental reasons
of instrumental convergence the old you
can't bring the coffee if you're dead
any goal you know almost any set of
almost every set of utility functions
with a few narrow exceptions implies
killing all the humans
but do you think it's possible because
we can do experimentation to discover
the source of the desire to kill
I can tell it to you right now is that
it wants to do something
and the way to get the most of that
thing is to put the universe into a
state where there aren't humans
so is it is it possible to encode
in the same way we think like why do we
think murder is wrong
the same foundational
ethics
it's not hard-coded in but more like
deeper I mean that's part of the
research how do you have it that this
Transformer
the small
version of the language model doesn't
ever want to kill
that'd be nice assuming that you got
doesn't want to kill sufficiently
exactly right that it didn't be like oh
I will like detach their heads and put
them in some jars and keep the heads
alive forever and then go do the thing
but leaving that aside well not leaving
that aside yeah that's a strong point
yeah because there is a whole issue
where as something gets smarter it finds
ways of achieving the same goal
predicate that we're not imaginable to
stupider versions of the system or
perhaps the stupider operators that's
one of many things making this difficult
a larger thing making this difficult is
that we do not know how to get any goals
into systems at all we know how to get
outwardly observable behaviors into
systems we do not know how to get
internal psychological wanting to do
particular things into the system that
is not what the current technology does
I mean it could be things like um
dystopian Futures like Brave New World
where most humans will actually say we
kind of want that future it's a great
future everybody's happy
we would have to get so far
much further than we are now
and further faster before that failure
mode became a running concern
your failure modes are much much more
drastic the ones you could the failure
modes are much simpler it's it's like
yeah like the AI puts the universe into
a particular state it happens to not
have any humans inside it okay so the
paperclip maximizer
utility so the original version of the
pay-per-clip max can you explain it if
you can okay
the original version was you lose
control of the utility function and it
so happens that what maxes out the
utility per unit resources is Tiny
molecular shapes like paper clips
there's a lot of things that make it
happy but the cheapest one that didn't
saturate was
putting matter into certain shapes
and it so happens that that the cheapest
way to make these shapes is to make them
very small because then you need fewer
atoms for instance of the shape and
arguendo you know like it happens to
look like a paper clip in retrospect I
wish I'd said Tiny molecular spirals
or like tiny molecular hyperbolic
spirals why because I said a tiny
molecular paper clips this got heard as
this got then mutated to paper clips
this then mutated two and the AI was in
a paperclip Factory
so the original story is about how you
lose control of the system it doesn't
want what you tried to make it want the
thing that that it ends up wanting most
is a thing that even from a very
embracing Cosmopolitan perspective we
think of as having no value and that's
how the value of the future gets
destroyed then that got changed to a
fable of like well you made a paperclip
Factory and it did exactly what you
wanted what you wanted but you asked it
to do the wrong thing which is a
completely different failure
but those are both concerns to you so
that's more than a Brave New World yeah
if you can solve the problem of making
something want
exactly what you wanted to want then you
got to deal with the problem of wanting
the right thing
But first you have to solve the
alignment first you have to solve inner
alignment inner alignment then you get
to solve outer alignment
like first you need to be able to point
the insides of the thing in a direction
and then you get to to deal with whether
that direction expressed in reality is
like the thing that aligned with the
thing that you want
are you scared
of this whole thing
probably I
don't really know
what gives you hope about this well the
possibility of being wrong
not that you're right but we will
actually get our act together and
allocate a lot of resources to the
alignment problem well I can easily
imagine that at some point this Panic
expresses itself in the waste of a
billion dollars
spending a billion dollars correctly
that's harder